hello and welcome to sums up a channel
about how to survive
in the online jungle my name is bradley
and today we're going to talk about face
recognition systems
how do they work can they be hacked and
what technologies are the most
secure
just take a look at this flickering
hellscape no this isn't some video from
a terrible nightclub
if you've got an iphone with face id
this same projection covers your face
every single day
and if you actually disassemble your
iphone and take a look under the hood so
to speak
you'll find a dot projector that creates
over 30 000 invisible dots on your face
and this how effectively builds your
face map
now human beings recognize other
people's faces thanks to an area of the
brain called the fusiform gyrus
at four months of age we begin to
recognize the faces of others
our brains begin to single out the key
points of the face
for instance the eyes the nose the mouth
and eyebrows
and this allows us to identify a person
looking at pretty much
one half of their overall face basically
our brain
averages all of the faces it sees and
then identifies deviations from this
average
and there are tons of facial recognition
methods so i'm not going to bore you
with terms like the delaunay
triangulation or the
viola jones methods instead i'll try to
explain everything in layman's terms
using
visualization a face recognition system
creates so-called
landmarks or points of the face these
locate
the face and then distinguish key
contours such as the
left eye the right eye the left eyebrow
the
right eyebrow nose lips and so on the
device
eventually obtains an image of you that
looks something like this
now the next step is drawing a mask the
mechanism here is based on triangulation
and uses those
landmarks that we've already talked
about now this is what that process
looks like
circles are drawn between every three
points the vectors are then
added to the circles the result is a
mask that looks something like this
by the way the same mechanism powers
masks in popular apps such as masquerade
for instance
landmarks are simply bound with 2d or 3d
projections
if the face moves then the landmarks
track its position
in turn helping the mask to adapt
people have been trying to fool
biometrics for a long time now for
instance this is how spoofing attacks
were presented in the early 90s
retina coding accepted warden william
smithers
be well yeah you too
you can see here that the overall
principle is correct
criminals need to outwit the biometric
sensor by presenting counterfeit
biometric evidence for valid user
our task therefore is to protect the
system from being fooled
four anti-spoofing measures two
parameters are of great importance the
first one is the false reject rate
this is when an honest user for whatever
reason cannot be identified by the
system
and gets labeled as a scammer as such
this user is denied access
and smashes their phone against the wall
the second one is the false acceptance
rate this is the
inverse when a scammer is misidentified
as an honest user what really matters
here is gaining a balance
perfectly balanced we need to on the one
hand protect against
criminals but on the second hand we need
to avoid these false accusations of
law-abiding users the release of the
iphone x sparked much debate around
facial biometrics the technology has
since become widely accessible
and is used in a variety of different
areas people have tried literally
everything to deceive face id they've
tried
photos oops didn't work as we know face
id is a 3d technology pre-recorded
videos and images projected on phone
screens didn't fall the sensor either
then professional mask makers took a
stab at defeating face id
but to no avail unsurprisingly the
iphone remained
undefeated still locked in fact when
apple first unveiled their
face id feature they specifically
mentioned that spoofs involving masks
would be rejected
so at first the only way to defeat this
space id feature was with
either identical twins or triplets you
should do it
yes do it oh
no i'm in
we can hardly call this a hack right i
mean could scammers really use this
as a method in the real world i don't
know i mean okay if i had a twin brother
i could read his messages
but there are no secrets between twins
anyway but then
no more than a week after face id was
released a vietnamese company named bkav
finally defeated this biometric
technology using a mask
unlike traditional silicone masks this
mask was made on a 3d printer using
stone powder
and its eyes were 2d infrared images
glued on a 3d model
now to prove their success bkav recorded
a video
they set up face id and demonstrated
that all
security settings were on and that the
mask easily unlocked the iphone
this particular hack uses the same
principle as identical twins
that's why the developers called this
mask the artificial twin
and all it took was about 200 to create
and by the way apple claims that face id
is much more secure than
for instance fingerprint sensors but
whereas fingerprint sensors have
a 1 in 50 000 chance of making a mistake
for face id the chance is
around one in a million now as far as
the real world is concerned
it's really unlikely that scammers will
have the motivation the
technology or the funds or even spy
secrets to
regularly defeat face id in this way
another popular technology is called
liveness now this is used by many
services worldwide to determine
whether or not a person on the other end
of the phone or computer screen
is in fact a real person computer says
no
these kinds of checks are essential for
online services such as crypto exchanges
or car sharing or really wherever you
need
verification and kyc aml procedures
basically new users are asked to move
their head around in front of a camera
during registration now this is how
companies tend to battle
things like payment fraud account
takeovers as well as bottom presentation
attacks
that's when scammers misrepresent
themselves with masks or digital images
for example
now at first glance liveness may
resemble that
face id these technologies have really
different tasks
i mean face id on the one hand compares
two faces
one that's stored in the iphone and
another that's presented to the camera
now the system therefore needs to
determine whether in fact those faces
match
on the other hand liveness needs to
understand whether a person is a human
being
rather than say a photo a mask or just
another presentation attack so let me
explain how liveness actually works
well first of all it needs to scan a
face to create a 3d map
it then analyzes specific properties
about the image like
noise texture and glare the way our skin
reflects light differs from silicone
masks or phone screens
and they have much more smoother
textures what's interesting here is that
a neural network detects
what the human eye cannot so when this
image is uploaded into the system
it's processed in depth and the system
can easily
identify forgery for instance now if you
move your head in front of a camera
the image might get affected a little
bit so as a person gets closer to the
lens
the proportions of their face may not
change evenly
for instance their nose might get bigger
now liveness technology is basically
designed to adapt
and interact with these changes so when
a person turns their head for instance
the system executes multiple checks
making it virtually impossible for
someone to pass
using a static image for instance and
this is why liveness is so good
at actually determining whether or not
there's a real human being standing
on the end of that camera and one of the
most reliable methods today
uses cameras to actually capture how
blood moves within the vessels of the
face
there was actually an experiment that
was carried out using samsung phones
during which blood flow beneath
the face was repeatedly measured turns
out this method guarantees 100
accuracy for determining whether a
person is real or not
yes it's kind of creepy but it's working
to sum up i'd say that you can pretty
much hack anything given the necessary
resources
the key component here needs to be the
motivation right
but anyway thanks for watching and i'll
see you next week be safe
[Music]
you